taking all of these factors into
consideration
there are four points of advice i want
to highlight
the first is to reinforce that adults
18 years and above should be vaccinated
and we strongly advise that they are
vaccinated
the benefits outweigh the potential
harms
i am a chess physician at the hospital
that i work at
we are now seeing young people who are
unvaccinated being admitted to hospital
with quite severe covet many of them
need
oxygen support and sadly some of them
also need a ventilator machine to help
them to breathe
much of that suffering can be prevented
or reduced through vaccination and so my
urge
to add out to our 18 years and above who
are not yet vaccinated
is that you strongly consider booking
your vaccine appointment
having the job and getting yourselves
and your friends and family protected
that's the first piece of advice the
second relates to healthy
16 and 17 year olds
we would like to advise that the first
vaccine dose is offered
now for 16 and 17 year olds who are
otherwise healthy
with the aim of a second vaccine dose to
be offered
sometime later and we will provide
another update of advice
regarding the exact details of the
second dose
the reason for wanting to provide advice
on the second dose separately
is because we're expecting more data to
accumulate in the coming weeks
and that means that we can offer advice
that is the most up-to-date
and the most relevant for the second
dose for this particular age group
i like to reflect that you may remember
in the uk
at the end of december last year
we chose to use a two dose schedule with
an extended
dose interval between the first and
second dose
by doing so that allowed us to
prioritize first doses
and have more people protected we also
know now that
by extending the interval between the
doses we achieve
a higher level of protection which can
translate into a longer duration of
protection
with regard to the current advice the
extended dose interval means that we are
in a position to offer advice on the
first dose
and still have time to look at new data
as they accumulate
before second doses are due
other countries that have chosen to use
a three-week interval between their
doses
will not have this option quite so
readily available
to them and that is maybe an important
difference
this advice for healthy 16 and 17 year
olds is new
and is in addition to their existing
advice
for 16 and 17 year olds who have
underlying health conditions that put
them at risk of severe covet
they have been eligible for vaccination
for many months now
and i hope most of them have been
vaccinated
the third point of advice is for
children
aged 12 to 15 years old we offered
advice for the last month in july
and that advice is unchanged at this
time
just to summarize there are two groups
of people
in the age bracket 12 to 15 years
who are revising vaccination for
these are people with specific
underlying health conditions that
put them at risk of severe covid and
also
12 to 15 year olds who are close
household contacts
of a person who is immunosuppressed and
this is because
immunosuppressed persons may not be able
to generate a good immune response even
if they themselves are vaccinated
as i said this advice is unchanged from
july
the last and fourth piece of advice that
i like to
put forward today is i like to highlight
the importance
of other immunization programs that are
routinely offered
to children and young people such as
meningitis
human papilloma vaccines and the
influenza
vaccine as we increasingly return to
life as normal
we need to catch up on these other
vaccine programs as well
and so i would say that if you are
eligible for one of these vaccines
and are offered these vaccines please do
not ignore them
just because we're in a pandemic they
are important
and they are safe thank you